il
on tremble et bonjour bonjour m et par
an vos voyages c'est ce sont des récits
de vie où on découvre l'existence la
réalité du coopérant canadiens en
mission
racontez nous cette scène vous êtes dans
un autobus en direction de jeux pensait
bobo dioulasso
oui il devait être le voyage et qui
partait de ouaga pour malabo pour aller
un petit plus pour boulot comme un
abonné de toulon le bobo dioulasso
bref pour ma ram formi d'ocha au niveau
de l'exportation là bas et je savais que
de partir en autobus pour être une chose
facile parce que je l'avais déjà c'est
moi par la route en voiture et je
connaissais les conditions de route mais
l'offre est mal je me suis payé la
traite royal maps comme monarchie assez
car leur affolé parce que il en a
redemandé pam à quelques jours suivre ce
voyage le côté kaka phonique tout ben
khaled à cet autobus l'eau le bruit
était infernal parce que les pièces de
métal s'entrechoquent et après elle les
bagages qui étaient aux déçus par ce
qu'on appelle le réhabilite dans l'avion
le vraiment tombé sous les thèmes des
voyageurs les jantes et ya des remèdes
finalement ils les laissaient d'asus
l'aller à ce que ben évidemment au juste
les films locaux
or ce n'était peut-être tu dans le deux
parties étaient incroyablement 1 est
douce et eau et la ctu m'avait dit c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui tombait
enceinte et dame marie launay on évoque
la bombe sur qui la prime ne suffit
vraiment et leurs veaux vaches cochons
sur la toiture
elle m'a dit oui à quelque chose là
évidemment on arrête quelques pas pour
aller par un pipi et le mois qui
essaient de débarquer avant
tout mon bagage parce qu'évidemment je
voulais pas laisser mon ordinateur mon
sac à main qui ma valise de quelques
jours dans l'autobus et le faux
évidemment la chine blanche alors en
défaveur de l'autobus ont macha de tous
les revendeurs de cacahuètes ou de
papier mouchoir pour aller à la salle de
bains que le plus de minutes que j'avais
pour pouvoir marrant mais je peux tu es
capable il a fallu que je revienne dans
l'autobus puis attendre le troisième
prochaines heures un pauvre marc un tel
pouvoir
on parle de votre énième voyage au
burkina faso troisième quatrième ou vous
êtes intéressé à l'art africain
vous êtes dans un atelier auprès d'un il
fait du bronze c'est sa spécialité de
finale à aline et qui aime à la caddel
réputation internationale vous êtes là
pour lui venir en aide même si c'est un
génie ou artistique il pas très
intelligent au plein marketing est venu
par an donc de cet homme qui est coincé
par évidemment les obligations
techniques qui lie à son métier mais
aussi par le poids politique les gens
les politiciens qui compte sur lui parce
qu'il a une réputation il faut qu'ils
remplissent la commande tout un poids
qui pèse sur ses épaules et vous
craignez la crise cardiaque ici je pense
arriver là en atelier en cette fin de
journée là je le voyais atterré
évidemment il fait travailler deux
autres artisans des fois le même ça va
jusqu'à 20 alors ces gens là qui a ni
pour être capable de vivre et l'autre
que de se voir dans un délai de 20 jours
pour réaliser un tel contrôle qui
presque pas avoir de fonds pour acheter
la matière première qui est très même
sur le marché et qui prie le
gouvernement de mettre un embargo sur
l'exportation de ses entrées là parce
que c'est avec ça qu'ils font leurs
branches et ça c'est devenu
presque de base pour le burkina alors
11e alors je comprends lucky saloperies
loges je sais que commun que je tirais
n'importe quoi s'affoler
y'a rien qui va rentrer parce que il est
trop la balle est opprimé alors ceux qui
écoutent viagra l'on va travailler aux
côtés on va le prendre une bière mais
jamais trop éviter quelques années par
une guerre mais là je suis vraiment le
celta lors il faut décompresser pour
afficher un ratio la chose à la fois
puis décanter cette histoire là et lui
redonner le goût de continuer d'avancer
parce que l'eau vraiment ajouté j'étais
vraiment à peu près même moi de le voir
dans cette situation était presque plein
il faut faire quelque chose il faut agir
vous avez joué le rôle de l'infirmière
vous l'avez médicamenté vous êtes vous
avez un feu mais est ce que c'est pour
cette raison que le wengé vous envoyer
le rencontrer au début bon c'est
toujours de les aider à l'exportation
mais un moment donné avant d'exporter il
faut avoir les bases pour exporter
puisqu'il ya des choses qui sont réglés
ben on va les régler avant d'exporter
parce que cela l'exportation ça va nous
sauter au visage alors il faut reprendre
l'abécédaire va et reprendre certaines
fonctions certaines opérations dans
l'entreprise et ne l'a évidemment que si
on n'a pas de matières premières
évidemment que si on n'a pas les
liquidités financières que même nos
propres gouvernements rayspan ou payer
pour être capable de faire nos
exportations il ya plein de choses à
régler alors six heures mais chut c'est
je me dis ce serait beau je pourrais me
construit ce mac os made up moment donné
mais il faut faire plus loin il faut
vraiment avoir plus loin il faut je
pense que ses fins car si on vous
demandait un homme
daniel tremblay vous avez accompli quoi
en dépensant les milliards de dollars du
groupe fédéral lors de vos tournées avec
votre ong qu'est ce que vous avez
accompli au burkina faso qu'est-ce que
vous avez changé c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup d'argent les pays développés il
ya des fois que je me remets en question
parce que je trouve qu'il ya un manque
de volonté des gens qu'on va aider mais
notre ong de par les années s est
ajustée et oblige aujourd'hui un petit
financement pour montrer qu'on intéresse
inhalent mars à bord de la petite
contribution c'est pas énorme et au
moins ça monte un peu d'intérêt et puis
effectivement on voit un changement dans
l'attitude des gens chez qui on va
porter main-forte finalement mais c'est
difficile de quantifier l'aide qu'on
apporte ses soeurs que bon il ya un
réveil qui se fait moi j'essaye de les
motiver de france est de vraiment avoir
confiance en eux mais ils ont tellement
aussi de contraintes locales qu il faut
ajuster salt et on a beau arriver avec
toutes les théories marketing du monde
l'eau mais qu'at il ya des contraintes
gso niveau de la température au niveau
de la nourriture tapas marché des
trois-ponts nantes en a mangé un depuis
les deux derniers jours et qui si sûr
que sa tête le sac règne dans ta tête à
46 46 degrés alors qui sauf que ça va
prendre distance à prendre l'énergie
mais il y en a qui réussit tout juste
s'il y en a un qui réussit c'est déjà
énorme
c'est déjà énorme parce qu'il donne
l'exemple aux autres ils vont motiver
d'autres épisodes mais je dirais que
dans mes groupes
j'ai été chanceuse parce que il y avait
de la volonté pas toujours mais en
général il y avait assez de volonté pour
dire oui on avance on continue puis il
faut il faut persévérer
mais il ya tellement contraintes aux
bertignac je lève mon chapeau aux as et
j'adore vraiment très bon qu'est ce que
vous prévoyez ce qui est des quelque
chose des projets qui sont dans les sons
dans les cartes présentement au niveau
des voyages d'un attention
destination au niveau de notre ong on
travaille sur des plans quinquennaux et
là on a des nouveaux pays qui viennent
d'apparaître
il ya la kazakhstan il ya le temps donné
la mongolie bon ça la mongolie c'est
précisément au niveau de l'éducation
alors ça c'est pas mon truc à moi mais
probablement qu'il y avait des
affectations soit tanzanie ou soit
kazakh ça je ne sais pas encore alors où
sont donc ces des confirmations je me
remets un contact avec vous qu'il faut
aussi parler mais c'est sur moi ça sera
moi un plaisir un privilège de pouvoir
recevoir à nouveau de vos nouvelles par
rapport à votre mission dans le monde
merci mais je pourrais vous faire
partager vous voulez dire sur skype par
exemple moment donné on ferait une
émission tam-tam canada une de nos
émissions hebdomadaires avec vous sur le
thème merci beaucoup daniel tremblay de
nous avoir contacté il ya presque très
agréable à votre compagnie